good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-470 to object
class euclid previously safe special
containment procedures as CP 472 is to
be kept in the center of an empty lot
cell measuring 37 by 37 meters all
personnel wishing to enter for research
purposes must undergo a psychological
evaluation and submit a research
requests before being permitted entry
personnel should not remain within 18
meters of the stone for more than five
minutes without being directly monitored
by security personnel update 472 one no
personnel exposed to scp-470 two through
stage six of its effects may be allowed
more than four consecutive minutes of
further exposure without direct approval
of site command update 472 - once every
60 days one d-class personnel must be
exposed to scp-470 - for a period of
between ten and twenty seven minutes
update for seventy-two three due to
biomass loss no personnel may be exposed
to scp-470 - more than once in a 48-hour
period without explicit approval by dr.
Amy Jones description scp-470 - was a
red garnet of the pyro spessartite
variety of unusual signs 1.8 carat the
phrase for man looketh on the outward
appearance but the Lord looketh on the
heart has been engraved in two
millimeter lettering on the stone
surface relevance of the phrases on
when any organism possessing a heartbeat
passes within an 18 meter radius of
scp-470 to that subject we'll begin to
hear the distant beating of a heart
within their head the heartbeat heard
directly corresponds with the subjects
own heartbeat with the frequency of the
palpitations increasing or decreasing
with the pulse of the subject prolonged
exposure causes a variety of additional
psychological effects stage 1 onset five
to seven minutes
low-level feelings of unease and anxiety
effects cease immediately on vacating
area stage two
onset six to 21 minutes gradually
increasing feelings of anxiety and
paranoia effects decrease on vacating
area and ceased within five minutes
stage 3 onset 18 to 27 minutes
high-level feelings of anxiety and
paranoia the subject begins to
hallucinate reporting seeing the world
around them tinged with red and hearing
vague whispering noises 27% of subjects
also reports strong feelings of guilt
effects decrease within 20 minutes of
ache hitting area and cease within 60
minutes stage 4 onset 34 to 59 minutes
previous symptoms increase
hallucinations become more vivid and
visual frequent hallucinations include
rivulets of blood trailing down the
walls images of dead bodies thumping
screaming and ambulatory corpse-like
figures 65% of subjects rendered
mentally incapable of leaving the
influence of scp-470 2 effects decrease
within 60 minutes of vacating the area
and cease within 3 hours
stage 5 onset 55 to 60 nine minutes
previous symptoms increase 100% of
subjects rendered mentally incapable of
leaving the influence of SCP 4
70 to 38% of subjects exposed enter a
state of catatonia this state has a 76
percent fatality rate if subjects are
not removed from a CP 472 s area of
influence effects decrease within six
hours of vacating area and cease within
24 hours
stage 6 onset 361 to 723 + minutes
surviving subjects now capable of
leaving the influence of scp-470 -
though many do not realize this unless
prompted previous symptoms vary in
degree and intensity and become sporadic
alternating with periods of lucidity
indefinitely until subject leaves or is
removed from the area effects cease
within 24 hours of vacating area scp-470
- was recovered from the mansion
residence of a wealthy man living in
foundation investigators were alerted by
local reports of hauntings by domestic
staff after he was hospitalized by a
fall mobile task force Delta 5
frontrunner was assigned to investigate
due to possible connection to ongoing
projects investigation narrowed down the
origin of the anomalous effects to
scp-470 - which has been prominently
displayed in jeweled collection origin
of scp-470 - is under investigation
SCP 472 does not appear to have any
other anomalous effects harmful or
otherwise object tentatively classified
as safe pending testing potential
downgrade - anomalous sea addenda
scp-470 2 was located via reports from
the so called anomalous community from
interfacing with mobile task force
sigma3 bibliography's initial theories
from anomalous community sources
categorized scp-470 2 as a seal
containing an entity responsible for
scp-470 twos anomalous effects however
further analysis has not supported this
rather indicating that scp-470 2's
appearance as a red garnet may be due to
a fundamental perception error of
unknown nature sources have not been
able to confirm anything substantial
about the origin or nature of scp-470 2
addendum 472 45 Effects of subsequent
exposure subjects previously exposed to
scp-470 2's effects experienced a
cumulative 10 to 20 percent increase in
the speed of the onset of certain
effects of scp-470 2 with each
additional exposure eventually subjects
will immediately begin experiencing
symptoms at stage 2 levels with stage 3
occurring within 5 to 10 minutes stages
4 to 5 then occur as normal the onset
time of stage 6 is not affected and
continues to occur no earlier than 361
minutes after initial exposure
hallucinations begin to differ in nature
when a subject is exposed to scp-470 to
more than one to five times subjects
report visions of a massive growing
collection of skinless organic material
resembling animal or human organs
muscular structures bones though no
recognizable bones etc join together in
a fashion that does not occur in nature
all subjects report multiple hearts
beating within the biomass sometimes
donning its surface after the fifth
exposure all subjects report seeing this
whether or not previous hallucinations
remain present or superimposed
additionally interviews with multiple
exposure subjects anomalous information
element see document and interview for
7201 65 B scp-470 2's object class has
been upgraded to euclid containment
procedures updated
addendum for 7207 t8 area of influence
conditional increase when no subjects
have been exposed to scp-470 2 for more
than 5 minutes within a period of 2
months its area of influence begins
increasing by a rate of 0.5 meters per
hour
expansion is temporary reverting back to
the original 18 meters area of effect
once a subject undergoes exposure
addendum 4 70 to 130 possible physical
biomass presence further testing with
subjects exposed multiple times to
scp-470 to indicating that the garnet
stone classified as scp-470 2 may in
fact be the only visible portion of a
much larger and continually increasing
biomass existing in so-called
transdimensional metaphor of the tip of
the iceberg object class pending review
additional containment measures also
pending review and ending 472 135
subject biomass alteration subsequent
testing of subjects exposed to scp-470 2
indicates that all subjects experienced
a 0.01 to one point 35 percent decrease
in biomass with each exposure to scp-470
two subjects remain unaware of this
event containment procedures updated
[Music]
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you for listening if indeed
you still are and you were all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob the reclusive extrovert James
Sabah Chris all hens I'd paw blue ice
917 Kareem Alaska we Justin day Thomas
Morin Kure kuma white crew and jayvo
jack crystal spice my archive curator
Nick Joseph Lewis sue eggy King modding
and the wanderer thank you all so much
for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well and some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the volga thank you
[Music]
you